taking a deep breath morning
[Music]
to get a lot of questions about about
Beth noticed lately my answer is
shredding Schrodinger's cat and bro we
haven't even looked in that box
I'm staying here yeah we don't we don't
we don't we got we got as many plans as
you do if you're a superfan then you got
theories and so do we
yeah it's great to be able to say that
and be honest it's like yeah this is we
don't we haven't made that choice yeah
you're smart people so you've probably
come up with some better better theories
worse theories overlapping theories
whatever but you know then we sit down
and we start writing and what becomes
can and becomes canon hey everybody is
Charlie so they're dropping new promos
for season four and because the DVD just
dropped they have all kinds of
commentaries so a couple really
interesting things came out of that
particularly them talking about the
origins of clone Beth and where they are
on the matter right now
is she a clone is she not a clone there
is a new round of the DVD giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video uh name a new winner at the end of
this but there are actually two
interesting moments in their commentary
one from the last episode which all
included a second here where Justin
talks about time travel which kind of
discounts some of the clone Beth
theories but also why they wrap things
up on a moment that didn't necessarily
answer the question of whether or not
she was a clone I sort of pushed it off
to a future season but also got her back
with Jerry because I like it's a finale
it needs to feel like a finale so it has
to be a big moment so then Justin says
Schrodinger's beth like they haven't
looked in that box yet because as Dan
Harmon said while they were negotiating
for season four like there's 70 new
episodes while they were working on that
they didn't do any work on the season
and based on some of the other things
that Dan Harmon's said on the commentary
track you can tell that they recorded
this commentary a little while before
they closed the deal for those 70 new
episodes because he still takes a couple
swipes at Turner but it also sounds like
in putting that off like they say that
you know people have theories some of
them might be better theories than what
they're thinking about right now but
eventually they'll sit down and what
they write will become the true Canon
based on some of the things that Justin
and some of the other producers have
said it's
sounds like they're really excited to
explore the idea of Beth being aware of
the central finite curve in the way that
Rick is the universe is basically an
animal and grazes on the ordinary
creates infinite idiots just to eat them
not unlike your friend Timmy Tommy
yeah hardly matters now sweetie you know
smart people get a chance to climb on
top take reality for a ride but it'll
never stop trying to throw you and
eventually it will there's no other way
off dad
I'm out of excuses to not be Who I am so
Who am I what do I do
my advice take off put a saddle on your
universe let it kick itself out so her
big thing was that she was starting to
question her true nature if I'm just
like you dad then can I keep denying
that and keep being the version of
myself that I am here the housewife
who's the mom to Morty and summer taking
that to its logical conclusion whether
or not she's a clone don't you think
then we will explore different versions
of Beth that made that choice and see
what Beth is capable of when she's more
like Rick remember I mean you know
Central finite curved so you have many
different versions we saw like the young
psycho version of her that was kind of a
joke but like the spectrum of Beth's
there's probably a lot out there that
are doing some really cool [ __ ] that
they can use for really cool stories so
think about that in the back of your
mind it Rick's clone argument was more
that all of it doesn't matter the
universe is gonna eat us all for
breakfast eventually anyway so you might
as well put a bow on it have some fun
while you have the chance to so just go
explore in the way that he explored
during the missing years they still
haven't addressed that either but they
did joke a little bit about the timeline
about how there's a little bit of
compression in the early seasons based
on the time that Rick shows up then
obviously during Morty's mind blowers
when we see a little bit more of him
when Morty was older I think the idea
there is that he wiped all their
memories because he came back for
birthdays may be multiple birthdays but
because this was happening in an episode
that was predicated on the idea that he
was erasing Morty's memory it's probably
something he's done on a regular basis
to the rest of the family but in the
episode 8 commentary they did say that
they wanted to do more Morty's mind
blowers episodes just because it gave
them so many opportunities to play
around in the timeline without having to
time-travel which is the thing that they
don't want to do I never intended for
this to be a you know substitute for
interment
none of us did we we had this all
planned out this was gonna air this was
gonna air 9th and then and then the
actual interdimensional cable 3 was
gonna air 12th in a world where we had
14 and then we would have done we've
done you know two more and I would have
been that but yeah we we had we had we
had due to numerous production snafus we
had that we had that we had to cut the
back doesn't that blow your mind there
were four extra episodes that they
intended on airing and they were gonna
do interdimensional cable so I think
that's also more evidence you know
sidebar for them doing 14 episodes of
season in the future if everything goes
well from a production standpoint
because like they imply that they had a
bunch of production issues that
prevented that and they had to cut the
back for from season 3 speaking of time
travel bringing you back around to clone
Beth or real Beth when he comes back
with the pizza most people were using
the amount of time it took him to get
those pieces to say that Beth was not a
clone because there wasn't enough time
to grow a clone Wally was doing this in
Justin roiland basically just threw that
out the window but important are we
gonna tell him on this commentary track
if she's a clone or not we don't know oh
I like this Rick Klein he's like by the
way I didn't steal it by the way yeah
but but but don't let it eat you alive
because in my opinion he went to a place
where time is different moves
he said that Rick went to a place where
time moves differently so ultimately I
think the takeaway is is they haven't
decided whether or not she's a clone so
you could argue either way but if you're
trying to use Rick's pizza to prove that
she's real you can't really do that
anymore but I'm still kind of leaning
back towards real bet at this point just
because of that conversation they have
the very first one where she's like you
tell me if I was a clone right and he's
like yeah of course I'd tell you but
then she starts to question her reality
and it starts to turn in on itself and
Rick looks like he gets
really pissed off that he still has to
be on the phone with her so he just
wants to end that conversation as fast
as possible so he'll say anything so I
think that he is being deceptive but I
do think the idea based on what they're
saying is is that we will get to the
idea of infinite Beth's and seeing
different versions of that people have
theorized about a Council of Beth's I
don't know if they'll take it that far
but let me know in the comments if they
do get into stories that deal with the
idea that Beth is just as smart or could
be just as smart as Rick what kind of
Beth episodes do you want to see them do
wouldn't be surprised that they did a
Beth the episode 5 rick jerry adventure
where they just go off together the fate
of the galaxy rests on your shoulders
let's go put some pants on
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner from my last video
Akhilesh please private message me so I
can get your contact details I'll name a
new winner when I post new Rick and
Morty
leave all your requests in the comments
below but click here to learn more about
those 70 new episodes and click here for
my new infinity war infinity gauntlet
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]